now Israeli media says an energy company
will begin testing a pipeline from an
offshore gas rig in the Eastern
Mediterranean now this comes days after
Israel rejected lebanon's request to
amend a draft Maritime border agreement
proposed by the United States now
Lebanon objects to three Clauses the
first relates to a borderline created by
Israel and marked by boys as you can see
there when its forces withdrew from
Lebanon in 2000 Lebanon wants the
language and the draft to be changed to
avoid accepting this line as an
international Maritime border it also
objects to the location of the Kanai gas
field in a Southern Lebanese exploration
block extending into Israeli Waters
Lebanon refuses to pay any percentage of
profits from that gas field to Israel
Israel says the field though may still
fall under its exclusive economic zone
the third relates to France's total
energies company Beirut wants the French
oil giant to work with Lebanon
separately and independently from its
projects with Israel rail well let's
speak now to Bernard Smith he's across
this forest from West Jerusalem Bernard
some complex terrain here and this
obviously isn't a new dispute can you
talk us through what this means and the
potential Fallout
well attempts have been going on for
years to demarcate the maritime border
between Israel and Lebanon that been U.S
brokered talks and they were pretty
close we understand to reaching a deal
last week though Lebanon wasn't happy
with the draft and particularly about
these boys that have been put in the
Water by the Israelis Lebanon didn't
want those to become identified as an
official International Maritime border
now this essentially seems to be having
a knock-on effect on a carish project
although this project is in Israeli
Waters it's a gas field that Israel is
getting ready to exploit and pump gas
from and there are reports today that is
going to start testing the pipes to see
if it's possible to see that
everything's secure there's no leaks a
standard sort of engineering testing now
the issue with karish is that previously
Hezbollah the iran-backed group in
Lebanon has said it could attack karish
if an overall agreement with Israel on
drilling rights is not reached now
previously Israel had been sort of
waiting for this agreement to be this
waiting for this agreement to assign
with Lebanon before it fully started
exploiting karish which is in its
territorial Waters Israel has now said
regardless of any deal with Lebanon it's
going to progress with this with his own
oil field now if these tests pan out
Israel says within weeks they could
start pumping oil that's from the Energy
company energian that is exploiting the
block with the Israelis so the question
is what is the risk to Israel of
starting to pump gas from karish bearing
in mind that it has not reached a full
deal with Lebanon over its Maritime
borders some more potential attention I
had there Bernard Smith across that
situation for us from West Jerusalem
thank you Bennett